marvel's avengers is the incredible hulk
of video games
just like bruce banner and his green
alter ego are two people within the same
body
avengers is split between two
personalities one is a single player
story campaign that can be emotional and
thoughtful as you play as each of
earth's mightiest heroes
the other is a multiplayer focused live
game where you punch lots of enemies
without really worrying about why
both sides work in their own way but
they never quite mesh
leaving marvel's avengers a somewhat
confused game but a fun one
despite all its inner turmoil
if we're going to stick with this hulk
metaphor then the single player campaign
is bruce banner
you start the game as kamala khan a huge
fan of the avengers who attends a
celebration called a day in san
francisco that quickly turns tragic the
avengers disband
and after a five year time skip it's up
to the idealistic kamala to convince the
heroes to reassemble
though you play as all of the avengers
over the course of the campaign the game
is at its best as it explores kamala
discovering her own identity as miss
marvel
and helping each of the characters deal
with the trauma and conflicts resulting
from mayday
but this is a superhero game and that
means there are super villains and they
need punching
the core of marvel's avengers is an
action rpg brawler with each character
building combos out of a host of melee
moves
ranged attacks and hero specific special
abilities
combat in marvel's avengers feels akin
to marvel spider-man or the batman
arkham games but the strength of
avengers is while
every character is stamped out of the
same template they all play very
differently from one another
iron man is more of a sniper than a
brawler hulk meanwhile gets buffs from
dealing and receiving damage so he's
best when waiting straight into combat
and smashing as much as possible
and kamala excels at knocking back and
controlling groups of enemies
in the campaign all those characters
allow you to explore different thematic
levels that play to each avengers
strengths but it also causes the story
to feel more disjointed
there's enough difference in the
characters that jumping from kamala to
hulk to iron man over the course of a
few levels
is more disorienting than it is
empowering there's not really an elegant
way for the game to onboard you with
each of the characters so the single
player campaign starts to feel more like
an extended tutorial
to get you ready for the live game
however the story is an engaging one
digging into the same kind of character
conflicts between the avengers that
added depth to the marvel cinematic
universe's take
it largely focuses on the relationship
between the exuberant kamala
and the reluctant banner who's fallen
into a depression and despair in the
years after a day
with banner kamala finds a superhero
mentor who helps her come to grips with
who she's becoming thanks to her new
powers while kamala helps give banner
the strength to step off the sidelines
when he has the ability to change the
world
i wish i could but i can't
but you're dr bruce banner the
relationship between kamala and banner
is what makes the campaign of avengers
work
and the time spent on developing these
characters makes them worth investing in
not everybody in the story gets an equal
amount of attention though
ms marvel banner and iron man are pretty
integral to the story and get a lot of
character growth
but black widow thor and captain america
are largely ignored
in practice the 10 to 14 hour campaign
feels like it shortchanges some of the
heroes to make room to cram in
the hulk side of marvel's avengers the
expansive multiplayer based live game
while many of the missions you play in
the single-player campaign are focused
on a single hero or maybe a pair of them
by about the halfway point they start to
get combined with four rays into the
multiplayer offerings of marvel's
avengers
these are missions of various sizes that
you usually take on with a team of three
other superheroes
those are either controlled by other
players who can join your team through
matchmaking or filled in with ai
controlled versions of the avengers
you've been ranking up throughout the
game
the trouble is couched within the story
campaign multiplayer missions stand out
as being a lot less focused
all the levels even the biggest ones are
pretty homogeneous since they need to
support all different characters equally
that turns them into little more than
big fighting arenas that don't play to
any particular strengths
they also kill the pace of the campaign
cutting back on character moments so you
can run around big chunks of the utah
badlands or the pacific northwest
marvel's avengers has all the trappings
of a live game like destiny 2
or the division with its social spaces
shopkeepers faction vendors and daily
activities
the explanations for all those things
are wedged in the middle of the campaign
and like the multiplayer missions they
feel at odds with what the story is
trying to deliver in its exploration of
its characters
once the campaign wraps up you're left
with just the multiplayer side which
runs on continually throwing more
challenging missions at you and gating
those missions with gear requirements
the live game runs on a loot system in
which you outfit your characters with
equipment that has various stats on it
the overall average of your stats
determines your power level which
dictates how strong you are in a fight
and which missions you're capable of
handling like other live games the
lootchase is supposed to be the engine
that drives your continued engagement
the chance that better more powerful
stuff is the reason to tune in
every day or every week with your
friends
on this front marvel's avengers
flounders a bit just about every piece
of gear has
interesting perks offering advantages
like defense against enemies with freeze
weapons or allowing you to shrink or
poison enemies as you pummel them
but it's only at the very top of the
loop grind as you near the cap of 150
power that you might actually start to
bother looking at the gear you're using
and what it does up until then even
items with good perks will get replaced
in short order since you'll continually
be picking up new gear with higher power
numbers
the good news is the loot chase isn't
really much of a loot grind
you can tear through levels at a pretty
consistent clip which keeps you from
ever feeling like you're gated from
content you want to play
and forced to play stuff you don't in
the end there's a fairly big swath of
activities you can take on
with varying lengths objective types and
difficulty levels
if you want a quick 10 minute experience
you'll have that option if you'd rather
dig in for 30 minutes or an hour or two
hours there are larger levels that can
keep you busy
the tougher they are the more skill they
demand from you in combat
and tapping into that depth is where the
game excels
but like the hulk himself it all feels a
bit chaotic and
unfocused you really don't need to pay
much attention to the loot chase
even though it's ever present in the
game despite a variety of objectives all
the levels are pretty samey
sending you to the same locations to
fight assortments of the same enemies
and when four heroes are wailing on a
big boss or a giant robot
you lose a lot of the nuance that makes
combat good because it's hard to see
through the confusion
[Music]
still marvel's avengers does manage to
scratch that live game itch
just like it scratches the itch for an
emotional superhero story
and when its combat comes together it
can be very fun
there's a lot to learn and master with
each character and their differences
help keep her playing missions fresh
with six characters in the base game
and more coming experimenting with each
one is a solid draw
on top of its disjointed nature marvel's
avengers has been marred with technical
issues and bugs at launch
like missing dialogue checkpoints not
working correctly
and enemies not spawning in during
missions most of these problems are
minor inconveniences
and some seem to have been lessened by a
patch since release
in the last few days though my game has
often suffered crashes and freezes
whenever i've played sometimes i can
play through a whole mission or two and
even get a couple hours out of a
playstation before a crash but other
times the game seizes up repeatedly over
a short period
i've managed to put a lot of hours into
avengers over the last week or so but in
the last few days as i've worked through
the end game
these problems have rendered the game
unplayable at times
time for a prison break on the whole
though i've enjoyed my time with
marvel's avengers
if crystal dynamics can deal with the
technical issues plaguing the game
i'm looking forward to spending time
mastering the combat styles of all the
characters
and exploring the expansions of its
story the live game has set up
as with bruce banner and the hulk it
seems like it'll be worth sticking with
marvel's avengers
to see how it might reconcile the two
halves of its personality in the future
to make something even better
you